de nos jours il reste encore de
véritables spécialistes de la main
baladeuse pour ces maniaques tous les
moyens sont bons pour parvenir à leur
misérable fin
épidémie de ma baladeuse semble
d'ailleurs ces derniers temps en être
recrudescence malgré les sanctions
prévues
[Musique]
souvent la même baladeuse ils sont des
gouttes sans arrêt sans arrêt partout
partout sur les fesses
même aux Champs-Élysées
[Musique]
au cinéma plusieurs fois plusieurs fois
comment ça s'est passé quoi
non pas du tout pourquoi les hommes font
ça à votre avis je ne sais pas si on est
sadique il y a beaucoup de malade
malheureusement actuellement il y en a
de plus en plus ça vous choque
certaines femmes en sont réduites à
longer les murs notamment avenue de
Wagram ou Séville depuis quelques temps
une bande de redoutable individus
[Musique]
oui très bien
les hommes qui ont la main baladeuse
qui sont Hardy quoi et puis alors on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas prendre le métro
sans se faire peloter ça vous arrive
parfaitement surtout si on a un peu de
fesses il faut vous situer les endroits
dans les régions en bas de notre
individu ça peut plaire
à quelques-unes c'est pas réservé aux
femmes en fin de compte je crois qu'il y
a des hommes qui mettent la main aux
autres hommes pourquoi pas après tout
bah oui ça change un peu c'est moi
choquant oui
personnellement j'apprécie pas il y a
d'autres manières pour avoir des filles
pour se défendre cet appareil
judicieusement placé il déclenche aussi
tout un signal sonore qui provoque la
confusion de l'agresseur
chose curieuse ce sont presque toujours
de jeunes femmes qui sont victimes de
ces larges attentats détails encore plus
étonnant si l'on écoute les hommes aucun
d'entre eux ne se livre à ce genre de
pratique elle provoque oui monsieur donc
c'est pas de la faute des hommes non
c'est la faute des femmes c'est la faute
mais vous vous le faites jamais jamais
non non ou jamais
parfois je regarde comme ça mais il y a
une certaine tentation mais
toujours pas fait le mettre dans dans ma
poche jamais arrivé c'est sûr c'est pas
joli ça c'est même d'avoir envie
oui mais il faut se retenir quand même
personne ne le fait mais tout le monde
connaît un voisin qui lui n'hésite pas
j'ai jamais fait vous êtes
sûrs
adressez-vous aussitôt un agent et
expliquez-lui avec la plus grande
précision ce qui vient de vous arriver
il interviendra efficace est-ce que dans
votre boulot vous êtes souvent victime
d'homme quand la main baladeuse non
jusqu'à maintenant ça m'a jamais arrivé
c'est dommage qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez cette manie de la manie de
bah au contraire ça prouve qu'on les
intéresse non donc vous n'êtes pas
contre par contre du tout sauf dans le
travail
là je suis tout à fait contre le reste
du temps
dans le métro c'est pas mal
ça change ça change de quoi ça change
les idées
[Musique]
d'ailleurs moi je m'en dévoue absolument
pas le besoin je sais on passera partout
dans l'ongleterre
d'où ça vient à votre avis peut-être une
carence intellectuelle une certaine
frustration je sais pas je peux pas vous
dire vraiment mais enfin moi
en aucun cas je m'en éprouve le besoin
ça me donne jamais l'idée
[Musique]